l'engorgement des tribunaux.
Davide G
- Entrée dans un univers où
soigner demande de l'empathie
et un certain sang froid.
- C'est quand même une
endroits de l'unité via caméra.
- L'unité deiaiaiaiatrie est
sécurisée, parce que plusieurs
patients sont très instables.
Dr Fl l l l l l l l l l l l l ll
- On a aussi des patients qui
e e e en détention à l'hôpital
parce qu'ils nous ont été
référés de l'Institut Pinel;
devant la Commission d'examen
des troubles mentaux.
- Attendre le feu vert des
tribunaux pour garder ou même
traiter des patients. C'est
du psychiatre Fouad Saher.
- Vous avez pris vos médicam
ou vous refusez toujours
de les prendre?
- Cette patiente refus
- Bien, c'est la cour qui va
décider, mais,pepepepepense que
vous avez besoin de prendre
vos médicaments, madame.
- (la i,i,i,i,i,i,i,i,i,i,i,i,it
hospitalisés sans qu'on aitle dr
la médication. Même si plusieurs
sont en psychose, et qu'ils ont
la réalité.
- Il faut toujours quand même
avoir une distance sécuritaire,
être sur ses gardes.
- Fouad Saher se dirige vers
garder plus longtemps.
(tumulte)
Le patient fait irruption
dans le corridor. Il faudrarsrsr
le jeune homme en détres
- Il a reçu des médicaments...
... plusieurs médicaments même;
il reste toujours très agité.
(cris du patient)
le stabiliser, il était en garde
en établissement, je viens
de demander une prolongation
- Les délais pour ce genre
de demandesésésésésésés
de quelques semaines à plusieurs
mois parce que les tribunaux
Dre CLAIRE GAMACHE, prés. Asso.
médecins psyQuQuQuQuQuQuQuébe
- Donc, en raison de
l'engorgement des Palais de
c'est vrai que les ordonnances
de traitement depuis 3 ou
4 ans... les délais ont beaucoup
augmenté. Donc, ça crée des
hospital s s s s s s s s s s s e
traiter le patient.- Vous êtes.s
le savez, vous êtes comme en
détention à l'hôpital jusqu'à
- (patient): Oui.
- Ici, 5 àlililililililits
seraient occupés par des
patients en attente d'une
Un problème surtout que,
depuis la pandémie, la demande
augmente en psychiatrie.
ÉRIC GAUTHIER, dir. program.
santé mentalquququququququququq,
on avait sept à huitnsnsnsnsnsne
à Laval quand on arrivait
le matin, là maintenant,
- De plus, il manque ici
une douzaine d
- On devrait être
31 psychiatres,- - - - - - - - e
dans la région voisine des
Laurentides. Pourtant le nombre
de psychiatres a augmenté
au Québec depuis 10
dans la région voisine des
Laurentides. Pourtant le nombre
de psychiatres a augmenté
Mais plusieurs boudent carrément
le travail en Hôpital.
- L'enjeu, c'est que là,
ces psychiatres-là trouvent
ça tellemeieieieieieieieieieieir
qu'ils ont tendance à quitter. %
dans le réseau hospitalier.
- À la la Cité-de-la-Santé
doubler le nombre de lits;
un problème pré
plusieurs autres région,
qui aj
en psychiatrie.
- Il faut se calmer un petit
pe
"dès qu'on sera calme,
on va pouvoir sortir." OK?
Radio-Ca